thomas avons joint alors quelle est
l'ambiance sur place
écoutez déjà plusieurs centaines voire
plusieurs milliers de personnes qui se
sont rassemblées ici on est à proximité
du jardin du luxembourg
plusieurs organisations politiques
associatives ou encore syndicales ont
lancé donc un appel à manifester pour
cette journée de samedi manifestations
dans le cadre des journée internationale
contre les violences des forces de
l'ordre ainsi que contre le racisme
c'est dans ce cadre là que s'inscrit
donc cette manifestation et avec
évidemment en point mire cette loi
sécurité globale qui a été adoptée cette
semaine au sénat avec quelques
réécriture et qui va donc retourner à
l'assemblée nationale évidemment ici
tous s'offusque de cette loi de sécurité
globale propose d'écouter de témoignages
il s'agit notamment d'un représentant de
l' ong amnesty international et puis da
du frère d'une victime présumée des
forces de l'ordre écouter ce micro
nicolas couper le droit d'expression
c'était un droit fondamental savez il
est inscrit dans la déclaration
universelle des droits de l'homme donc
c'est la démocratie la démocratie repose
sur la liberté d'expression donc tout ce
qui met en cause cette liberté
d'expression mais il faut qu'on se batte
il faut qu'on soit là pour pour
conserver ses liberté d'expression la
liberté de manifestation le manier la
possibilité de manifestations grave
sans violence bien sûr un pacifique mais
pour nous c'est des combats essentiels
aujourd'hui le fait de ne pas pouvoir
filmer ça va donner encore plus de
possibilités aux policiers de sévir
aujourd'hui si tout le monde connait
george frey c'est parce qu'il ya eu les
vidéos
sinon aujourd'hui on nous aurait dit
georges floyd est mort d'une crise
cardiaque
aujourd'hui si tout le monde connaissait
drechou via c'est parce qu'il a usé ses
vidéos avant que les vidéos elle me
sorte on nous avait dit cédric julia est
mort d'une crise cardiaque
aujourd'hui tout le monde connaît michel
est claire s'il n'y avait pas eu ces
vidéos michel est claire sans prison je
vous rappellerai de ces policiers qui
ont tabassé michel éclair de son
domicile
en vingt ans de métier combien de fois
ont-ils s'est vite dans cette procédure
dans ses écrits on a vu qu'on a pu
constater ils ont fait défaut écrit
combien de fois ont-ils fait défaut
écrit voilà pourquoi est-ce que vous
devons film et c'est un devoir pour
pouvoir montrer la vérité des exactions
voilà pour quelques-unes des
revendications exprimées ici il ya
beaucoup de personnes au profil très
différent parce que je voulais et des
organisations politiques syndicales je
vois par exemple le droit au logement
qui est présent ainsi qu'une association
sans papiers il ya également des gilet
jaune vous l'avez dit qu'ils ont fait le
déplacement avec aussi une scène qui a
été monté une scène mobile on a pu voir
tout à l'heure à sa traoré prendre la
parole devant cette foule il faut le
composent et donc de plusieurs centaines
de personnes au moins pour l'instant on
verra lorsque le cortège va s'élancer
combien ils sont réellement le cortège
devrait d'ailleurs s'est lancé dans les
toutes prochaines minutes
merci à thomas pour toutes ces
précisions